hör mal warum kann boris nicht eine zeit
lang bei mir wohnen bis eine lösung
gefunden ist es wäre auch besser für die
kammer das ist groß genug es gibt
eigentlich klar was du da gerade sah ja
weißt du ein ausländer einkuppeln den
würde ich doch auch bei mir unter bringt
sich zwei trennen werden sie nicht
einfach wieder zwei einzelne sie bleiben
die hälfte eines ganzen das aber nun
zerbrochen ist wenn sie auch noch kinder
haben wird der alltag zum kampfgebiet
das heißt das ist nicht mehr mein
zuhause kommt das alles anders parkett
das war alles ich das sollte sich dass
die ökonomie der liebe heißt der film
des belgiers jacques himmler fonds auf
deutsch im original ökonomie die kuppler
eine liebe hört auf eine beziehung muss
abgewickelt werden
der film erzählt wie die beiden
protagonisten loris und marie versuchen
bei ihrer trennung wie vernünftige
erwachsene aus zu sehen und wie es ihnen
nicht gelingt die geschichte spielt fast
nur in den fünf zimmern und im garten
vor dem haus
dennoch hat sie nichts kammerspiel
haftet die ist der die cam des
kameramanns lässt den hauptdarstellern
sehr viel raum
der widerstand ist in der erinnerung an
das vergangene glück übrigens müssen für
alle beteiligten eine kleine hölle
gewesen sein
allein die erste einstellung soll 80 mal
gedreht worden sein andere text 20 30
mal
aber vielleicht ging es ja auch nur
darum den erschöpfungszustand der film
beschreibt wirklich nahe zu kommen